Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. To corrupt more people with his doctrine, at Blackheath, where 200,000 of the commons were gathered together, John Ball began a sermon in this fashion. When Adam delved and Eve span, who then was a gentleman? And continuing his sermon, he tried to prove by the words of the proverb that he had taken for his text, that from the beginning all men were created equal by nature,
感谢您收听《历史余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。为了用他的教义腐蚀更多人，在布莱克希思（Blackheath），当20万平民聚集在一起时，约翰·鲍尔（John Ball）以这种方式开始了布道。当亚当耕种、夏娃纺纱时，谁又是绅士呢？他继续布道，试图用他作为文本的谚语来证明，从一开始，所有人天生都是平等的，
and that servitude had been introduced by the unjust and evil oppression of men against the will of God, who, if it had pleased him to create serfs, surely in the beginning of the world would have appointed who should be a serf and who a lord. Let them consider, therefore, that he had now appointed the time wherein, laying aside the yoke of long servitude, they might, if they wished, enjoy their liberty so long desired. Wherefore they must be prudent, hastening to act after the matter of a good husband, tilling his field and uprooting the tares
而奴役是人类不公正和邪恶的压迫所引入的，违背了上帝的意愿。如果上帝乐意创造农奴，那么在世界之初，他肯定会指定谁该做农奴，谁该做领主。因此，让他们考虑一下，他现在已经指定了时间，在这段时间里，他们可以放下长期奴役的枷锁，如果他们愿意，就可以享受他们渴望已久的自由。因此，他们必须审慎行事，像一个好丈夫那样迅速采取行动，耕种他的田地，拔掉稗子，
that are accustomed to destroy the grain. First, killing the great lords of the realm, then slaying the lawyers, justices and jurors, and finally rooting out everyone whom they knew to be harmful to the community in future. So at last, they would obtain peace and security if, when the Great Ones had been removed, they maintained among themselves equality of liberty and nobility, as well as dignity and power. So that is a very disapproving account by Thomas Walsingham, a monk at St. Albans Abbey, of an open-air sermon given in 1381
这些稗子习惯于毁坏谷物。首先，杀死王国的大领主，然后杀掉律师、法官和陪审员，最后铲除所有他们认为未来会对社区有害的人。这样，他们最终将获得和平与安全，如果在大人物被清除后，他们在彼此之间维持自由、高贵、尊严和权力的平等。这就是托马斯·沃尔辛厄姆（Thomas Walsingham），一位圣奥尔本斯修道院（St. Albans Abbey）的僧侣，对1381年举行的一次露天布道的非常不赞成的描述，
by a certain John Ball Tom, a priest who played a key part in what came to be known as the Peasants' Revolt. So I did the Peasants' Revolt at school. And generally, I have to say, maybe this says a great deal about my school outside Wolverhampton in the 1980s, but the boys' sympathies were very much on the side of the king and not of the peasants. Now, that would amaze you, Tom. I'm astonished to hear that. I haven't massively deviated in that. I haven't massively deviated.
由某个约翰·鲍尔（John Ball）汤姆（Tom）所作，他是一位在后来被称为“农民起义”（Peasants' Revolt）的事件中发挥了关键作用的牧师。我在学校里学过农民起义。总的来说，我不得不说，也许这很大程度上说明了我在20世纪80年代伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton）郊外学校的情况，但男生们非常同情国王，而不是农民。现在，这会让你感到惊讶，汤姆。听到这个我感到很震惊。我在这方面并没有发生巨大的偏离。我没有发生巨大的偏离。
I'm astounded to hear that, Dominic. I mean, I guess one of the reasons might be that the young king is only 14. So perhaps if you're a boy studying the account, you would identify with him perhaps. But I think there's a certain irony there because although John Ball, those famous lines, when Adam delved and Eve span, who was then a gentleman, these are kind of iconic in the history of English radicalism,
听到这个我感到很惊讶，多米尼克。我的意思是，我想原因之一可能是年轻的国王只有14岁。所以也许如果你是一个学习这段历史的男孩，你可能会认同他。但我认为这其中有一种讽刺，因为虽然约翰·鲍尔那句名言“当亚当耕种、夏娃纺纱时，谁又是绅士呢”，在英国激进主义史上是标志性的，
the history of English egalitarianism. At the same time, I think that there is a certain sense in which the idea that this is a peasants' revolt is incorrect. Actually, this is a revolt led by people, Dominic, who might perhaps better be described as Middle England. This is where Middle England is starting to discover its voice. So it's part of the paradox and fascination of this whole extraordinary event, which really is extraordinary.
是英国平等主义的历史。与此同时，我认为在某种意义上，认为这是一场“农民起义”的想法是不正确的。实际上，这是一场由多米尼克所说的人领导的起义，也许用“英格兰中部”（Middle England）来形容他们会更合适。这就是英格兰中部开始发现自己声音的地方。所以这是整个非凡事件的悖论和魅力的一部分，这确实是非凡的。
In a sense, if this is the wellspring of English radicalism, then it's the start of something very, very kind of new. And what makes it different to previous revolts? There'd been revolts throughout medieval England. Edward II had been deposed. Barons had risen against John. There'd been a civil war in the reign of Stephen and Matilda. Barons siding with rival kings. But this is different because this is not led by magnates. This is not led by peers. This is led by a class of person who, until this moment, has not been heard really on the public stage of England. So this is the common people of England making their entrance in the history books. And that is why for anybody on the left, particularly the
从某种意义上说，如果这是英国激进主义的源头，那么它就是某种非常、非常新的事物的开始。是什么让它与之前的起义不同呢？中世纪的英格兰一直有起义。爱德华二世曾被废黜。男爵们曾反抗约翰王。斯蒂芬和玛蒂尔达统治时期曾发生过内战。男爵们站在敌对国王的一边。但这不同，因为这不是由权贵领导的。这不是由贵族领导的。这是由一类人领导的，直到这一刻，他们在英国的公共舞台上还没有真正被听到过。所以这是英国的普通民众在历史书中登场。这就是为什么对于左翼人士，特别是
kind of intellectual left in Britain, the Peasants' Revolt has come to be seen, hasn't it, as a sort of foundational moment. So it's the kind of event that if you are a Jeremy Corbyn or something, it's one of the landmarks in your kind of personal history of England and Englishness, isn't it? And there are always articles in The Guardian saying, everyone should do the Peasants' Revolt at school. It's such an important moment. Socialism began with the Peasants' Revolt, all this kind of stuff. Yeah, so Ken Loach, the very pro-Corbyn film director,
英国的知识分子左翼，农民起义已经被视为一个奠基时刻，不是吗？所以，如果你是杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）之类的人，这就是你个人英国和英国性历史中的地标之一，不是吗？《卫报》上总是有文章说，每个人都应该在学校学习农民起义。这是一个如此重要的时刻。社会主义始于农民起义，诸如此类。是的，所以肯·洛奇（Ken Loach），那位非常支持科尔宾的电影导演，
he opened a memorial to the Peasants' Revolt on Smithfield, where there was another famous confrontation, which we'll come to in due course. There's absolutely the sense in which this is the kind of thing that Billy Bragg would make a song about, or something like that. I think there's no question that it really does deserve this reputation. Judith Barker, who wrote a brilliant book about this, she doesn't call it the Peasants' Revolt very significantly.
他在史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield）为农民起义揭幕了一座纪念碑，那里曾发生过另一场著名的对抗，我们稍后会谈到。绝对有一种感觉，这就是比利·布拉格（Billy Bragg）会为此写一首歌之类的事情。我认为毫无疑问，它确实配得上这种声誉。朱迪思·巴克（Judith Barker），她写了一本关于此事的精彩著作，她非常重要地没有称其为“农民起义”。
She calls it the Great Revolt. In her book, England Arise, she says that the rebels did not seek personal advancement, but a radical political agenda, which if it had been implemented, would have fundamentally transformed English society. I think that's absolutely true. Nigel Saul, in his biography of Richard II, says of this revolt that what happened in 1381 was altogether unique. Dominic, it probably won't surprise you to know that merely interpreting it as socialism avant l'électre isn't entirely right. It is slightly more complicated than that, and that's precisely what makes it so fascinating and interesting. To put it into a bigger context, Tom, this is an uprising in southern England in the late 14th century, and it's become this sacral moment, dare I say, for the bearers of the left-wing flame. But it is also an episode in a long-running struggle that we've already devoted four podcasts to, because this is effectively part of our epic series on the Hundred Years' War, isn't it? The great struggle between England and France in the high Middle Ages. So maybe we should recap a bit to remind people who listened to
她称之为“大起义”（Great Revolt）。在她的书《英格兰崛起》（England Arise）中，她说叛乱分子寻求的不是个人晋升，而是一个激进的政治议程，如果实施的话，将从根本上改变英国社会。我认为这绝对是真的。奈杰尔·索尔（Nigel Saul）在理查二世的传记中说，1381年发生的事情是完全独特的。多米尼克，仅仅将其解释为“超前社会主义”并不完全正确，这可能不会让你感到惊讶。它比那要复杂得多，而这正是它如此迷人和有趣的原因。为了将其置于更大的背景下，汤姆，这是14世纪末英格兰南部的一场起义，它已经成为左翼火焰承载者们的一个神圣时刻，我敢说。但它也是我们已经投入了四期播客的长期斗争中的一个插曲，因为这实际上是我们关于百年战争（Hundred Years' War）史诗系列的一部分，不是吗？中世纪盛期英格兰和法国之间的大斗争。所以也许我们应该回顾一下，提醒那些听过
the Hundred Years' War and to explain to people who didn't what's been going on and why it is that England has been pushed to this position where the common people, as it were, are desperate to kind of have their say and make their entrance onto the stage. Right. So we did a four-episode series on the Hundred Years' War, and it was full of English heroism and victory, battles of Crecy and Poitiers. And then we did a 10-minute coda, didn't we, where basically it all went wrong and suddenly the English found themselves losing. And essentially at the high tide of English success, Edward III, the great conquering king, had made himself lord of pretty much half of France. But by the time that Edward III, the great conquering king, had made himself lord of
百年战争的人，并向那些没听过的人解释发生了什么，以及为什么英格兰会被推到这种境地，即普通民众迫切地想要发表意见并登上舞台。好的。所以我们做了一个关于百年战争的四集系列，里面充满了英国的英雄主义和胜利，克雷西（Crecy）和普瓦捷（Poitiers）战役。然后我们做了一个10分钟的尾声，不是吗？基本上一切都搞砸了，突然间英国人发现自己输了。本质上，在英国成功的鼎盛时期，伟大的征服者国王爱德华三世（Edward III）已经使自己成为了几乎半个法国的领主。但当爱德华三世，那位伟大的征服者国王，使自己成为
pretty much half of France. But by the time that Edward III dies in 1377, all those victories have slipped away and England is really left in France with two continental possessions. Calais, which has been reconstituted as part of England, and Gascony in the southwest of France. Edward III, this great conqueror, he slipped into his dotage. He's become the plaything of a highly avaricious woman called Alice Peres, who is much hated across England. The Black Prince, Edward III's son and heir, Victor at Poitiers, he has died. And when Edward dies, he is succeeded by the Black Prince's son, so Edward III's grandson, Richard II, who succeeds Edward on the 21st of June, 1377, and he is aged 10 years old.
几乎半个法国的领主时。但当爱德华三世在1377年去世时，所有的胜利都溜走了，英国在法国实际上只剩下两个大陆领地。加来（Calais），它已被重建为英国的一部分，以及法国西南部的加斯科尼（Gascony）。爱德华三世，这位伟大的征服者，陷入了老糊涂。他成为了一个名叫爱丽丝·佩雷斯（Alice Peres）的极其贪婪的女人的玩物，她在整个英国都备受憎恨。黑太子（Black Prince），爱德华三世的儿子和继承人，普瓦捷的胜利者，已经去世了。当爱德华去世时，继位的是黑太子的儿子，也就是爱德华三世的孙子，理查二世（Richard II），他在1377年6月21日继位，当时他才10岁。
And this is not good for England. In the Middle Ages, it's terrible to have a child as a king. And a truce has been in existence, but it ends three days after the death of Edward III. And the moment it ends, a French fleet descends on the south coast of England. It ravages it. In 1378, the English launch a campaign to try and capture a range of ports along the north French coast to complement Calais. This is an utter disaster. Then in December 1379, an entire fleet is shipwrecked off Cornwall. Essentially, everything is going completely tits up for the English in the Hundred Years' War. It's terrible. Now, England relative to France is very small. It doesn't have the huge
这对英国来说不是好事。在中世纪，有一个孩子做国王是可怕的。休战协议一直存在，但在爱德华三世死后三天就结束了。它结束的那一刻，一支法国舰队降临在英国南海岸。它蹂躏了那里。1378年，英国发动了一场战役，试图夺取法国北海岸的一系列港口以补充加来。这是一场彻底的灾难。然后在1379年12月，整支舰队在康沃尔（Cornwall）外海沉没。本质上，英国在百年战争中的一切都彻底搞砸了。太可怕了。现在，英国相对于法国来说非常小。它没有法国拥有的巨大
resources of land that France has. It's quite difficult for the English king to raise money. But if you're fighting a war against France, it has to be paid for somehow. And under Edward III, this radical development had been enshrined that essentially taxation can only be imposed on the people of England with the consent of the king's subjects as represented in parliament. And this is something really unusual in the context of medieval Europe. This idea that the commons should have a voice in how much money the king should be given to wage his wars becomes a fundamental principle with very, very enduring consequences for the future course of English history. And when you say the commons, these are, for the avoidance of doubt,
土地资源。英国国王筹集资金非常困难。但如果你正在与法国进行战争，它必须以某种方式支付。在爱德华三世统治下，一项激进的发展被确立，即本质上，只有在议会代表的国王臣民同意的情况下，才能对英国人民征税。这在中世纪欧洲的背景下是非常不寻常的。这种认为平民应该在国王应该获得多少资金来发动战争方面有发言权的想法，成为了一项基本原则，对英国历史的未来进程产生了非常、非常持久的影响。当你提到平民（commons）时，为了避免歧义，
these are not politicians as we would recognise them. These are kind of local gentry, bigwig type people who are representing the interests of the property classes, effectively, such as they are. Yeah, they're kind of JPs, prosperous landowners, that class of person. So it's justices of the peace, JPs. Justices of the peace, yeah. And as landowners, they have a feeling that everybody in the country should shoulder the burden, that they should not be the only ones coughing up. And they feel that lots of wage earners in the country aren't really pulling their weight. And so their solution to
这些不是我们所认识的政治家。这些是地方乡绅、大人物类型的人，他们有效地代表了财产阶级的利益。是的，他们是治安法官（JPs）、富裕的土地所有者，那一类人。所以是治安法官，JPs。治安法官，是的。作为土地所有者，他们有一种感觉，即全国的每个人都应该分担负担，他们不应该是唯一掏钱的人。他们觉得国内的许多工薪阶层并没有真正尽到自己的责任。所以他们解决
this problem in parliament is to introduce a poll tax whereby a flat levy is imposed and everyone has to pay it. And this is introduced in January 1377. And everyone has to pay for it. The only people who don't are children under the age of 14 and beggars, vagrants. But otherwise, everyone has to pay four pence. Now, this isn't a prohibitive sum. You could buy maybe a dozen eggs for four pence. Now, this isn't a prohibitive sum. You could buy maybe a dozen eggs for four pence. And it's very easy to collect because you just go around and grab it from everyone. And it's viewed as a success. It raises enough money to enable the war effort to be funded. And then it's so successful that two years later, another poll tax
议会中这个问题的方法是引入人头税（poll tax），即征收统一税，每个人都必须支付。这在1377年1月被引入。每个人都必须支付。唯一不支付的人是14岁以下的儿童和乞丐、流浪者。但除此之外，每个人都必须支付四便士。现在，这并不是一个高不可攀的金额。你可能可以用四便士买到一打鸡蛋。现在，这并不是一个高不可攀的金额。你可能可以用四便士买到一打鸡蛋。而且它很容易收集，因为你只需要到处走走，从每个人那里拿走它。它被视为一种成功。它筹集了足够的资金来资助战争努力。然后它太成功了，以至于两年后，另一个人头税
is introduced. This one is more finely graduated. So you have 15 categories going from the very poorest who are still paying four pence, right the way up to almost seven pounds for the richest. This money is invested in the fleet that then sinks off Cornwall. Oh dear. So it's a kind of disaster. People have the feeling that all this money has been raised and they have nothing to show for it. It's kind of like HS2, this railway that's had billions and billions lavished on it to link London to Manchester, and it's not going to reach the middle of London and it's not going to reach Manchester. So there's a slight feeling
被引入。这次分级更细。所以你有15个类别，从仍然支付四便士的最贫穷的人，一直到最富有的人支付近七英镑。这笔钱被投资在后来在康沃尔外海沉没的舰队上。天哪。所以这是一种灾难。人们有一种感觉，所有的钱都筹集了，但他们什么也没得到。这有点像HS2，这条耗资数十亿、数十亿的铁路，旨在连接伦敦和曼彻斯特，但它无法到达伦敦市中心，也无法到达曼彻斯特。所以有一种轻微的感觉，
all this money has been wasted and the government is incompetent. And what adds to the sense of fury about this is the feeling that the guys who are leading the Hundred Years' War, who are Edward III's surviving sons, are basically glory hunters in it for the glory of their own names, but also they're fundamentally incompetent. The youngest of Edward III's sons, a guy called Thomas of Woodstock, he's desperate to emulate his brother, the Black Prince, who'd won the Battle of Poitiers. In 1380, he takes a large group of knights and men and they go on a chevauchée, which is a kind of raid where you march across France, burning and looting everywhere you go to try and bring the French out to have a battle.
所有的钱都被浪费了，政府是无能的。加剧这种愤怒感的是一种感觉，即领导百年战争的人，也就是爱德华三世幸存的儿子们，基本上是荣耀猎人，为了他们自己名字的荣耀，但他们从根本上也是无能的。爱德华三世最小的儿子，一个叫托马斯·伍德斯托克（Thomas of Woodstock）的人，他迫切想要效仿他的哥哥黑太子，后者赢得了普瓦捷战役。1380年，他带着一大群骑士和士兵进行了一次“骑行劫掠”（chevauchée），这是一种突袭，你穿过法国，烧杀抢掠，试图引诱法国人出来进行一场战斗。
And you can kind of unleash your archers and your men at arms and win a decisive victory. But the French don't play that game. They learned their lesson. And they sign a deal with the Duke of Brittany, who had previously been an English ally. The English army gets the shit. It's all a disaster. In January 1381, Woodstock basically gives up, comes home, and that is the end of that campaign. Meanwhile, the son of Edward III, who is by miles the most powerful figure in England at this time, is John of Gaunt, born in Ghent, so hence his name.
你可以释放你的弓箭手和武装人员，赢得决定性的胜利。但法国人不玩那个游戏。他们吸取了教训。他们与布列塔尼公爵（Duke of Brittany）签署了一项协议，后者之前曾是英国的盟友。英国军队倒了大霉。这一切都是一场灾难。1381年1月，伍德斯托克基本上放弃了，回到了家，那场战役就此结束。与此同时，爱德华三世的儿子，他是当时英国最强大的权势人物，是冈特的约翰（John of Gaunt），出生在根特（Ghent），所以因此得名。
Who makes this famous speech, doesn't he, in Shakespeare? He does. This septidile about England, which is always quoted as the epitome of Englishness, and everybody forgets that John of Gaunt was actually... It was widely detested. Yeah, everybody hated John of Gaunt. Yes. And part of the reason why he's widely detested is that he is by miles the richest person in England. His income is around, it's kind of probably more than double the next richest magnate in England. But he is also very keen on claiming a throne for himself in Spain. And so he's endlessly raising money to go off and try and do that. And he's also darkly suspected of
他在莎士比亚的作品中发表了那段著名的演讲，不是吗？他确实发表了。这段关于英国的七行诗，总是被引用为英国性的缩影，每个人都忘记了冈特的约翰实际上……他被广泛厌恶。是的，每个人都讨厌冈特的约翰。是的。他被广泛厌恶的部分原因是他是英国最富有的人。他的收入大约是英国下一个最富有权贵收入的两倍多。但他也非常热衷于为自己在西班牙争取王位。所以他不断地筹集资金去尝试做这件事。而且他也被暗中怀疑
aspiring to become king himself. He's cast in the role of the wicked uncle. Because he is so rich and because he is so lavish in drawing attention to the fact that he's rich, he's a very obvious symbol of the imbalances and the iniquities in England. The ultimate symbol of this is his great palace, which he builds on the Strand, which is the road that runs from the city of London to Westminster, which is the center of royal power. And it's called the Strand because it runs along the banks of the Thames. And he builds this great palace, the Savoy Palace, which is where when King John of France had been captured by the Black Prince at the Battle of
渴望自己成为国王。他被塑造成邪恶叔叔的角色。因为他太富有，而且因为他如此大张旗鼓地引起人们对他富有这一事实的注意，他是英国不平衡和不公正的一个非常明显的象征。这最终的象征是他建造的宏伟宫殿，位于河岸街（Strand），这是从伦敦城通往威斯敏斯特（Westminster）的道路，威斯敏斯特是王权的中心。它被称为河岸街，因为它沿着泰晤士河岸延伸。他建造了这座宏伟的宫殿，萨沃伊宫（Savoy Palace），当法国国王约翰在普瓦捷战役中被黑太子俘虏时，
Poitiers, that's where he'd been put up. So it's a house fit for a king, a palace fit for a king. Enorm enormous complex. It's got kind of beautiful gardens and orchards running down to the Thames and everyone in London and beyond hate John of Gaunt for it. So these figures are wildly unpopular and the sense starts to develop that people are being screwed out of taxes simply to fund their egos and their adventures. This is why in November 1380, when the King's government says, well, we need more money, we can't maintain the war without more money, very, very reluctantly, Parliament grants a third poll tax. This doesn't go down well at all, partly because, as we've said, people feel the money is
那就是他被安置的地方。所以这是一座适合国王居住的房子，一座适合国王居住的宫殿。巨大的建筑群。它有美丽的泰晤士河畔花园和果园，伦敦及其他地区的每个人都因此而憎恨冈特的约翰。所以这些人物非常不受欢迎，人们开始产生一种感觉，即人们被榨取税款仅仅是为了资助他们的自我和冒险。这就是为什么在1380年11月，当国王政府说，好吧，我们需要更多的钱，没有更多的钱我们就无法维持战争时，议会非常、非常不情愿地批准了第三次人头税。这根本不受欢迎，部分原因正如我们所说，人们觉得钱
just being squandered, but also because this poll tax is much, much harder to pay. So whereas the previous ones for the poorest level had been four pence, now it's raised to 12 pence per person. So that's a significant increase. And it is justified by people assuming that the well-off will help the poor to pay it, but there's no mechanism in place for them to do that. So you're kind of dependent on hard, avaricious men doing the decent thing. Behaving like Victorian philanthropists. Exactly. But Tom, can I just ask a quick question? You said they need this money to pay for the war and the perception is the war is just to advance the interests of powerful men. Is that right?
只是被挥霍了，但也因为这个人头税更难支付。所以，虽然之前对最贫穷阶层的税是四便士，但现在提高到每人12便士。所以这是一个显著的增长。而且它的合理性在于人们假设富人会帮助穷人支付，但没有机制让他们这样做。所以你有点依赖于那些贪婪的硬汉去做体面的事情。表现得像维多利亚时代的慈善家。正是如此。但汤姆，我能问一个简短的问题吗？你说他们需要这笔钱来支付战争，而人们的看法是战争只是为了推进权势人物的利益。那是对的吗？
Is it just to advance the interests of powerful men? Or is there still this thinking, which we talked about when you did your brilliant 100 Years War series, that the English felt they had to launch the war as a preemptive attempt because France was so much more powerful, so they had to carry the war to France? So is there a genuine sense of national security involved with the war, or is it really, are the critics right, and is it just about egotism? Yeah, I think initially, when French fleets are descending on Southampton or Rye or whatever, then people feel, yes, this is justified. But by 1381, this is no longer the case. In fact,
这只是为了推进权势人物的利益吗？还是仍然存在这种想法，即我们在你做精彩的百年战争系列时谈到的，英国人觉得他们必须发动战争作为先发制人的尝试，因为法国要强大得多，所以他们必须把战争带到法国？所以战争中是否涉及真正的国家安全感，还是批评者是对的，这仅仅是关于自我主义？是的，我认为最初，当法国舰队降临南安普敦或莱伊（Rye）等地时，人们觉得，是的，这是合理的。但到了1381年，情况不再如此。事实上，
the tax continues to be levied even after Thomas Woodstock has come back from France. People definitely feel that this is an unjustified tax. Unsurprisingly, what happens is when the tax collectors go out, people just refuse to pay it. There's an incredible shortfall. This is an opportunity for Parliament to row back on it. They could have done that, but instead they doubled down and they send out commissioners who are told essentially, do not allow people to get out of paying this. And they're given very, very detailed instructions. They have to travel in person from village to village, from place to place, registering absolutely everybody. And there's one person who becomes particularly notorious for this, who's a guy called John Legg, who is a sergeant at arms, a royal sergeant at arms, so from the King's own household. And he supposedly looks up the skirts of young women to see if they are sufficiently mature to pay the poll tax. And this causes, as you can imagine,
即使在托马斯·伍德斯托克从法国回来后，税收仍在继续征收。人们绝对觉得这是一项不合理的税收。不出所料，当税务员出去时，人们只是拒绝支付。出现了令人难以置信的缺口。这是议会退缩的机会。他们本可以那样做，但相反，他们加倍努力，派出了专员，基本上被告知，不要允许人们逃避支付。他们得到了非常、非常详细的指示。他们必须亲自从一个村庄走到另一个村庄，从一个地方走到另一个地方，登记绝对每个人。有一个人因此变得特别臭名昭著，他是一个叫约翰·莱格（John Legg）的人，他是军士长，皇家军士长，所以来自国王自己的家庭。他据称掀起年轻女性的裙子，看看她们是否足够成熟来支付人头税。这导致了，你可以想象，
incredible outrage. So people are not happy about this. They feel that they're being screwed out of money that is then being squandered on foreign quarrels that has absolutely nothing to do with them. So there is great resentment towards the royal princes, but also towards the entire structure of royal government and two figures in particular. There's a guy called Simon Sudbury, who's the Archbishop of Canterbury, but also since January 1380 has been the Lord Chancellor. There is a guy called Sir Robert Hales, who's prior of one of those orders of warrior monks
令人难以置信的愤怒。所以人们对此并不高兴。他们觉得他们被榨取了钱财，而这些钱财随后被挥霍在与他们毫无关系的外国争端上。所以对王室王子们有很大的怨恨，但也对整个王室政府结构和两个特定人物有怨恨。有一个叫西蒙·萨德伯里（Simon Sudbury）的人，他是坎特伯雷大主教，但自1380年1月以来也一直担任大法官。有一个叫罗伯特·黑尔斯爵士（Sir Robert Hales）的人，他是那些武僧骑士团之一的院长，
like the Knights Templar. The Templar had gone by this point, but the Knights Hospitaller, which Robert Hales is the prior of, they're still very much around. They have lots of properties in London and across England. And he, at the beginning of 1381, is appointed the Lord High Treasurer. So these two men are kind of blamed for everything that's going wrong. But there is also out in the shires, out in the counties, massive resentment of anyone who is held responsible for administering this tax. So this would include justices of the peace, MPs, and sheriffs. So it's not a coincidence that this is the time when all the legends of Robin Hood start to kick off.
像圣殿骑士团。圣殿骑士团此时已经消失了，但医院骑士团（Knights Hospitaller），罗伯特·黑尔斯是其院长，他们仍然非常活跃。他们在伦敦和整个英国拥有许多财产。他在1381年初被任命为财政大臣。所以这两个人被指责为一切出错的原因。但在郡县里，在各县里，对任何被认为负责管理这项税收的人也有巨大的怨恨。所以这包括治安法官、国会议员和警长。所以罗宾汉（Robin Hood）的所有传说开始兴起并非巧合。
The Robin Hood ballads, which are celebrating somebody who robs from the rich to give to the poor. I mean, that's the claim, isn't it, that's later made. Yeah. You can see where the Robin Hood story gains traction at this point in time. Absolutely. And those stories of Robin Hood are expressive of a kind of popular hostility towards people who are seen in the elites in a sense of identification with people who are sticking up for themselves. And the readiness of the commons, the common people, as they would be called by the elites, not to accept their status, not to accept their station, is compounded by, of course, the most catastrophic event in the 14th century. Indeed, perhaps you might say in the whole of European history, which is the Black Death. So Dominic, we love kindling, don't we, on the
罗宾汉民谣，赞美一个劫富济贫的人。我的意思是，那是后来提出的主张，不是吗？是的。你可以看到罗宾汉的故事在此时此刻获得了吸引力。绝对如此。那些罗宾汉的故事表达了一种对被视为精英阶层的人的普遍敌意，以及对那些坚持自己立场的人的认同感。而平民，即精英阶层所称的普通民众，不接受他们的地位，不接受他们的阶层的准备，当然，被14世纪最灾难性的事件所加剧。事实上，也许你可以说是整个欧洲历史上，那就是黑死病（Black Death）。所以多米尼克，我们喜欢引火物，不是吗，在
Restless History? There are two metaphors that we like. One is the storm clouds of war, and the other is lighting the kindling, lighting the spark, sometimes a fuse if you're kind of post-early modern. Right. We're in kindling territory here, are we? We're very much in kindling territory because what has happened since the Black Death, the Black Death hits England in the late 1340s, the population has fallen from around maybe 6 to 7 million in the 1340s to 3 million by the 1380s. I mean, that is a stupefying collapse. And the consequence of that is obviously that there's a shortfall in labour. And the consequence in turn of that is that wages go up. And obviously for the landowning classes,
《历史余味》？我们喜欢的两个隐喻。一个是战争的乌云，另一个是点燃引火物，点燃火花，如果你是后早期现代时期，有时是导火索。对。我们现在处于引火物领域，是吗？我们非常处于引火物领域，因为自黑死病以来发生了什么，黑死病在14世纪40年代末袭击了英国，人口从14世纪40年代的约600万到700万下降到1380年的300万。我的意思是，那是一个令人震惊的崩溃。其后果显然是劳动力短缺。而随之而来的后果是工资上涨。显然对于土地所有者阶层来说，
this is terrible. They don't want to have to pay more money. And so there are desperate attempts to try and rein this back. And in 1351, the Statute of Labourers is introduced, which is basically a kind of massive pay freeze. The idea is that everyone should work for wages that were set before the Black Death had hit. And it coincides with also an attempt by landowners to uphold the traditional rights that they exert over unfree labourers on their land. So these would be the vilains, the serfs, the peasants. And the laws that govern this, they are very variable. They're very fluid, but there is kind of certain constants that the landowners can insist on. So vilains are not allowed to sell their land. They're not allowed to leave it for more than a day without allowed to sell their land. They're not allowed
这太可怕了。他们不想支付更多的钱。所以有绝望的尝试试图控制这一点。1351年，引入了《劳工法》（Statute of Labourers），这基本上是一种大规模的工资冻结。想法是每个人都应该为黑死病袭击前设定的工资工作。它也恰逢土地所有者试图维护他们对土地上不自由劳工行使的传统权利。所以这些将是维兰（vilains）、农奴、农民。管理这一点的法律，它们非常多变。它们非常灵活，但土地所有者可以坚持某些常数。所以维兰不允许出售他们的土地。他们不允许离开它超过一天，而不
to leave it for more than a day without the permission of their lord. They have to work for several days a week on the land of their lord. That might just be one day, but in certain places, it could be up to five or six days. So, pretty oppressive. They have to attend his court every three weeks. And when the serf dies, the Lord can claim a tax called the heriot, the dead serf's most valuable possession, which is normally a cow or something like that. So all of this generates massive resentment. And because there are fewer peasants in the wake of the Black Death, they are in a position actually to fight back against this. So they can move to places that offer better wages. They can buy up land themselves. And essentially, the focus for these tensions between the peasants who are trying to cast off the legal restrictions of the past and the landlords who are trying to double down on them, the focus for this becomes written documents. you will have abbeys, landlords, whatever, drawing up legal documents and using them
得到他们领主的许可。他们必须每周在领主的土地上工作几天。那可能只是一天，但在某些地方，可能多达五到六天。所以，相当压迫。他们必须每三周参加一次他的法庭。当农奴去世时，领主可以要求征收一种叫“死者税”（heriot）的税，即死去的农奴最值钱的财产，通常是一头牛之类的东西。所以所有这些都产生了巨大的怨恨。而且因为黑死病后农民减少了，他们实际上处于能够反击这一点的位置。所以他们可以搬到提供更好工资的地方。他们可以自己购买土地。本质上，这些试图摆脱过去法律限制的农民与试图加倍限制他们的地主之间的紧张关系的焦点，变成了书面文件。你会让修道院、地主等起草法律文件并使用它们
in courts to impose wage restraint and to impose the rights that lords traditionally have been able to impose. And likewise, this means that for the peasants, for the villains, legal documents, lawyers, scholars, abbeys, monks, anywhere where there is a paper record, these become objects of absolutely intense hatred. Lawyers are the enemy, Tom. Lawyers are the enemy. Absolutely so. And so, Dominic, it's not surprising then that the people who lead this kind of mood of insurrection are those who are doing best, the rustics, the peasants, the people out in the country, who are actually kind of bettering themselves, who are getting on their bike, if you like,
在法庭上实施工资限制和强加领主传统上能够强加的权利。同样，这意味着对于农民、维兰来说，法律文件、律师、学者、修道院、僧侣，任何有纸质记录的地方，这些都成为了绝对强烈的仇恨对象。律师是敌人，汤姆。律师是敌人。绝对如此。所以，多米尼克，那么领导这种起义情绪的人是那些做得最好的人，即乡下人、农民、乡村里的人，他们实际上是在改善自己，他们是在骑上自行车，如果你愿意的话，
and going off to find work, who are investing the wages that they're developing in land, who are interested in becoming homeowners and all this kind of thing. There's a Thatcherite revolt. That's what you're basically saying, Tom. Well, these are Sandbrook's people, aren't they? I mean, these are... I'm glad you think I have a people. Upwardly mobile, middle England. These are not the kind of the labourers at the absolute bottom of the pile. These are people who are trying to attain a new social status for themselves. And it's not a coincidence, I think, that they are most heavily concentrated in Kent, in East
去寻找工作，他们正在投资他们正在发展的工资在土地上，他们有兴趣成为房主和所有这些事情。这是一场撒切尔式的起义。这就是你基本上在说的，汤姆。好吧，这些人是桑布鲁克（Sandbrook）的人，不是吗？我的意思是，这些人是……我很高兴你认为我有自己的人。向上流动的英格兰中部。这些不是处于底层堆栈的劳工。这些人是试图为自己获得新社会地位的人。而且我认为，他们最集中在肯特郡、东
Anglia, in the home counties around London, because these are the areas that are profiting most from the development of capitalism in Flanders, where English wool is being exported. And these are people who are able to share in the wealth that is starting to be generated in this period. Right. So that's the interesting thing about the so-called Peasants' Revolt, that the epicentres of it are the most affluent parts of England at that time. Absolutely. And so it's in that sense, I think, that the Peasants' Revolt is indeed a misnomer. So Nigel Saul says of this, the revolt of 1381 was not a movement of the poor and the downtrodden.
安格利亚（Anglia）、伦敦周围的家郡（home counties）并非巧合，因为这些地区从佛兰德斯（Flanders）资本主义的发展中获利最多，英国羊毛在那里被出口。这些人能够分享在这个时期开始产生的财富。对。所以关于所谓的农民起义，有趣的是，它的震中是当时英国最富裕的地区。绝对如此。所以从这个意义上说，我认为农民起义确实是一个用词不当。所以奈杰尔·索尔对此说，1381年的起义不是穷人和受压迫者的运动。
It was a movement of the more ambitious and assertive in society. And Tom, I am amazed you haven't made this point because it's a really good point that you've made in your notes. You point out that these are the places that will actually become the heartlands of the Protestant Reformation in England. Those parts of the country with most continental links, those parts where people are more likely to be aspirational, individualistic, free-thinking, because they're better off. Yes. And we know from the study of revolutions that it's invariably not the very poor. It's always those who have aspirations that they feel are being repressed by a pre-existing elite. I think that this is exactly the situation that we have in 1381. In the years that precede
它是社会中更雄心勃勃和更自信的人的运动。汤姆，我很惊讶你没有提出这一点，因为这是你在笔记中提出的一个非常好的观点。你指出这些地方实际上将成为英国新教改革（Protestant Reformation）的心脏地带。那些与大陆联系最紧密的国家部分，那些人们更有可能具有抱负、个人主义、自由思想的地方，因为他们更富裕。是的。我们从革命的研究中知道，它总是并非非常贫穷的人。总是那些有抱负的人，他们觉得被现有的精英所压制。我认为这正是我们在1381年所处的情况。在之前的几年里
this great revolt, you see, particularly in East Anglia and Kent, a growing mood of insurrection. So you start seeing rustiki, these upwardly mobile peasants, they start to organise strikes. They refuse to take part in the haymaking and the harvesting and so on. They do mass trespasses on land that is set aside for the Lord to go hunting or whatever, kind of mass trespassing, mass poaching. And you start to get sporadic examples of the burning down of places where legal documents are stored, the legal documents that specify the dues and services that they owe. So Juliet Barker in her book, England Arise, gives the example of Lakenheath, which is a manor in Suffolk, which is owned by the great Abbey of Bury St. Edmunds.
这场大起义，你看到，特别是在东安格利亚和肯特，一种日益增长的起义情绪。所以你开始看到“乡下人”（rustiki），这些向上流动的农民，他们开始组织罢工。他们拒绝参加干草制作和收获等工作。他们在为领主狩猎而预留的土地上进行大规模非法侵入，或者其他什么，某种大规模非法侵入、大规模偷猎。你开始得到零星的例子，烧毁存储法律文件的地方，那些指定他们欠下的会费和服务的法律文件。所以朱丽叶·巴克（Juliet Barker）在她的书《英格兰崛起》中，给出了莱肯希思（Lakenheath）的例子，这是一个萨福克郡（Suffolk）的庄园，由伟大的圣埃德蒙兹伯里修道院（Abbey of Bury St. Edmunds）拥有。
Abbeys are at least as oppressive in this situation as the more secular landlords. In 1371, the vicar in Lakenheath leads the villagers in an attack on the abbot's officials who are trying to come in and take goods from people who haven't paid the poll tax. And the villagers basically won't have it. They attack the officials, they break the staff of office of the guy who's in charge of them, and they are so threatening that the Abbey's commission has just run away. Then in 1379, the entire village is fined for breaking the statute of labourers. So that's the law that's been brought in in 1351 to try and regulate how much people can be paid. And throughout the 1370s, you can see that in this one village, resentment and hatred of the Abbey of Bury St Edmunds, and by extension, the government that is lying behind these demands for poll taxes is just becoming greater and greater and greater.
在这种情况下，修道院至少和更世俗的地主一样压迫。1371年，莱肯希思的牧师领导村民袭击了修道院长的官员，他们试图进来并从没有支付人头税的人那里拿走货物。村民们基本上不接受。他们袭击了官员，打断了负责人的职权杖，他们非常有威胁性，以至于修道院的委员会只是跑掉了。然后在1379年，整个村庄因违反《劳工法》而被罚款。所以这就是1351年引入的试图调节人们可以获得多少报酬的法律。在整个14世纪70年代，你可以看到在这个村庄里，对圣埃德蒙兹伯里修道院的怨恨和仇恨，以及延伸到这些对人头税要求背后的政府，正变得越来越大。
And so Dominic, as we have said, it is a tinderbox awaiting the spark. Oh, that's great, Tom. Because I see in your notes, you've written these words, the poll tax is the straw that breaks the camel's back. That's right. So, I mean, we would never mix our metaphors on the rest is history. No, it's the spark that breaks the camel's back. Well, the storm clouds of revolt are gathering.
所以多米尼克，正如我们所说，这是一个等待火花的火药桶。哦，那太棒了，汤姆。因为我在你的笔记中看到，你写了这些话，人头税是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草。那是对的。所以，我的意思是，我们永远不会在《历史余味》中混淆我们的隐喻。不，它是压垮骆驼的火花。好吧，起义的乌云正在聚集。
And after the break, the storm will break. The tinderbox will light up. The camel's back will break. Yeah, with a great splintering. Return after the break to see these exciting metaphorical developments in the Peasants' Revolt. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. exciting metaphorical developments in the Peasants' Revolt. Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
休息后，风暴将爆发。火药桶将被点燃。骆驼的背将被压断。是的，伴随着巨大的碎裂声。休息后回来看看农民起义中这些令人兴奋的隐喻发展。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。农民起义中令人兴奋的隐喻发展。会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。
Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom, when and how does the storm break? When does the Peasants' Revolt kick off? Well, we've been talking about how this kindling box is lurking in East Anglia and Kent. But actually, Dominic, the first recorded act of violence in 1381 against the poll tax is in your neck of the woods. It's very near Bicester. Bicester. So home now to a very well-known, one of Europe's leading retail outlet, Parks, Bicester Village. It starts there.
欢迎回到《历史余味》。汤姆，风暴何时以及如何爆发？农民起义何时开始？好吧，我们一直在谈论这种引火物箱是如何潜伏在东安格利亚和肯特的。但实际上，多米尼克，1381年针对人头税的第一起有记录的暴力行为是在你的地盘。它非常靠近比斯特（Bicester）。比斯特。所以现在是欧洲领先的零售奥特莱斯之一，比斯特购物村（Bicester Village）的所在地。它从那里开始。
It does. So what happens is that the Dean of Bista sends a tax collector out. He gets set upon by a group of people who've disguised themselves. He gets roughed up. They beat him up. They cut off the ears and tails of his horse, and then they nail them to the local pillory, where they are the objects of much mockery. And the name of this tax collector, Dominic, is absolutely brilliant. That's what I'm laughing at. He's called William Payable. So Bill Payable.
确实。所以发生的事情是，比斯特的院长派出了一个税务员。他被一群伪装自己的人包围了。他被粗暴对待。他们打了他。他们割掉了他马的耳朵和尾巴，然后把它们钉在当地的枷锁上，在那里它们成为了许多嘲笑的对象。而这个税务员的名字，多米尼克，绝对是绝了。这就是我笑的原因。他叫威廉·佩亚布尔（William Payable）。所以比尔·佩亚布尔（Bill Payable）。
I don't believe that. I don't believe that. I just don't believe it. It's like if you said to me, his name is Thomas Tax or something. His name is Bill Payable. Bill Payable. I think you've been the victim
我不相信。我不相信。我只是不相信。这就像你对我说，他的名字是托马斯·税（Thomas Tax）之类的。他的名字是比尔·佩亚布尔。比尔·佩亚布尔。我想你已经成为了受害者
of some historical practical joke, surely. No, it's absolutely true. And the Bishop excommunicates these unknown ruffians and nothing further happens. But then in Essex, it's in Essex really that it all kicks off. So on the 30th of May, you get these assessment teams that are being sent out to try and uncover all these people who should have paid the poll tax who've just vanished off the record. This assessment team turns up in Brentwood in Essex, and they have some very notorious figures in this commission. So there is a guy called John Bampton who is notoriously corrupt.
某种历史恶作剧，肯定。不，这是绝对真实的。主教将这些不知名的暴徒逐出教会，没有发生进一步的事情。但随后在埃塞克斯（Essex），实际上是在埃塞克斯，这一切都开始了。所以5月30日，你得到了这些评估小组，他们被派出去试图发现所有那些应该支付人头税却刚刚从记录中消失的人。这个评估小组出现在埃塞克斯的布伦特伍德（Brentwood），他们在这个委员会中有一些非常臭名昭著的人物。所以有一个叫约翰·班普顿（John Bampton）的人，他臭名昭著地腐败。
I mean, he's the kind of embodiment of the corrupt elite. So he's an MP. He's a JP, a Justice of the Peace. He is a bailiff who is notorious for coming down hard on Rustique, Bill Aynes, who break the labour laws. Very hated. There is a guy called Sir John Guildsborough, who is an MP, but not just an MP. He's the Speaker of the House of Commons. This is a very radical innovation. It had been introduced in 1376 in the so-called Good Parliament.
我的意思是，他是腐败精英的化身。所以他是一名国会议员。他是一名治安法官，一名治安法官。他是一名以严厉打击违反劳动法的乡下人、维兰而闻名的法警。非常令人憎恨。有一个叫约翰·吉尔兹伯勒爵士（Sir John Guildsborough）的人，他是一名国会议员，但不仅仅是一名国会议员。他是下议院议长（Speaker of the House of Commons）。这是一个非常激进的创新。它是在1376年所谓的“好议会”（Good Parliament）中引入的。
All the parliaments in this period have brilliant names. In the Good Parliament, he serves as spokesman for the MPs who are trying to rein in Alice Peres, the avaricious mistress of Edward III. And they appoint a speaker so that he can be their spokesman. And John Gillsborough now is the speaker. He's the guy basically who's introduced the poll tax. And he's a close friend of Thomas of Woodstock. So he's a very, very provocative figure. So this commission goes in, John Bampton and Sir John Gillsborough, and they summon representatives from all the neighbouring villages to demand the money. And what happens is that you get a guy from a place called Fobbing, which is a small village.
这一时期的所有议会都有着响亮的名字。在“好议会”中，他担任议员们的发言人，试图约束爱德华三世贪婪的情妇爱丽丝·佩雷斯。他们任命了一位议长，以便他能成为他们的代言人。约翰·吉尔斯伯勒现在就是议长。他基本上就是那个引入人头税的人。他是托马斯·伍德斯托克的密友。所以他是一个非常、非常具有挑衅性的人物。于是，这个委员会出发了，约翰·班普顿和约翰·吉尔斯伯勒爵士召集了所有邻近村庄的代表来索要钱财。随后发生的事情是，一个来自福宾（一个小村庄）的人站了出来。
Again, an implausible name, I would say. But absolutely true, kind of on the marshy edges of the county. And this guy, Thomas Baker, stands up and declares forthrightly that nobody is going to pay a single penny more because they've already paid the tax. And indeed, they have receipts to prove it. Bampton, he's not going to put up with this, so he orders his men to arrest Baker. Violence ensues, Dominic. This is the straw. This is the spark. This is when it all kicks off. And Bampton and his men are forced to run away. They realize that they're massively outnumbered.
再说一次，我觉得这名字听起来不太可信。但这是千真万确的，那个村子就在郡里沼泽边缘地带。这个叫托马斯·贝克的人站起来，直截了当地宣布，没有人会再多付一分钱，因为他们已经交过税了。事实上，他们有收据为证。班普顿可不吃这一套，于是他命令手下逮捕贝克。多米尼克，暴力冲突随之而来。这就是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草。这就是导火索。一切就是从这里开始的。班普顿和他的手下被迫逃跑。他们意识到自己的人数处于绝对劣势。
And because of this, the villagers realize that they've crossed the line because you can't just try and kill royal commissioners. And so they're nervous about this. But at the same time, because it's 16 villages and because these villages are represented by leading figures, there's a feeling that, well, these are well-respected figures. We could perhaps make a stand here. Particularly if we can try and get other kind of leading figures from villages across the rest of Essex to join us, perhaps we can make a point. This is what happens.
正因如此，村民们意识到他们越界了，因为你不能随便试图杀害皇家专员。所以他们对此感到紧张。但与此同时，因为涉及16个村庄，而且这些村庄由领头人物代表，人们觉得，嗯，这些都是受人尊敬的人物。我们或许可以在这里坚持立场。特别是如果我们能争取到埃塞克斯郡其他村庄的领头人物加入我们，也许我们能表达出我们的观点。事情就是这样发生的。
Well, this is also presumably they're thinking, if we have a revolt and we prevail we will escape punishment that's exactly what they're thinking i think yeah but if we just say oh dear that was a mistake and we go home we will be punished exactly so in other words it's it's kind of you know in for a penny in for a pound oh god that's another terrible cliche but no well let's go for it let's yeah a clichetastic episode. So what this is not is a load of peasants reaching for their pitchforks and charging around willy-nilly. This is much, much more coordinated, and it's coordinated by people who have horses,
嗯，他们大概也在想，如果我们发动起义并取得胜利，我们就能逃脱惩罚，我想他们确实是这么想的。是的，但如果我们只是说“哎呀，那是个错误”然后回家，我们就会受到惩罚。没错，换句话说，这有点像“既然已经开始了，就得坚持到底”。哦天哪，这又是一个糟糕的陈词滥调，但算了，让我们继续吧。是的，这是一个充满陈词滥调的一集。所以，这绝不是一群农民拿起草叉到处乱冲。这要协调得多，而且是由那些有马的人协调的，
because basically the leaders of this uprising in Brentwood, they now get on their horses and go galloping across the county, trying to establish links with matching figures in other villages, in other regions of the county. Some start to go out to open meetings across Essex. For instance, on the 2nd of June, you have a mass assembly at a place called Bocking, which is north of the town of Chelmsford. Everyone swears a formal oath. Oaths are taken very, very seriously in the Middle Ages. I mean, this is not a light step at all. And the oath these various representatives of Bocking
因为基本上，布伦特伍德这次起义的领导者们现在骑上马，在郡里飞奔，试图与其他村庄、郡内其他地区的领头人物建立联系。有些人开始去参加埃塞克斯各地的公开会议。例如，6月2日，在切姆斯福德镇以北一个叫博金的地方举行了一次大规模集会。每个人都发了正式誓言。在中世纪，誓言是非常、非常严肃的。我的意思是，这绝不是一个轻率的举动。而博金的这些代表们所发的誓言
swear is to destroy divers legions of the king and to have no law in England except only those which they themselves moved to be ordained. So this is a very radical agenda, really, really radical agenda. And it Really, really radical agenda. And it suggests that probably, you know, these are ideas that have been circulating in the region beforehand. They're not just kind of spontaneously coming up with them. Possibly in the aftermath of the Black Death, Tom, as people are moving up and down the social scale and there's so much fragmentation and dislocation that these new ideas are coming in. Right. But also possibly due to the teachings of a particular figure who we will come to a little bit later on, but who you mentioned at the very start of the program. So John Ball, who we'll come to later on. Oh, John Ball. Yeah. This is the area where John Ball has been operating and probably we are seeing the impact
是摧毁国王的各种军团，并且在英国除了他们自己提议制定的法律外，不承认任何法律。所以这是一个非常激进的议程，真的非常激进。这表明，可能这些想法在之前就已经在该地区流传了。他们并不是凭空想出来的。汤姆，可能是在黑死病之后，随着人们在社会阶层中上下流动，社会出现了如此多的碎片化和错位，这些新思想才随之而来。没错。但也可能归因于我们稍后会提到的一位特定人物的教导，也就是你在节目开头提到的那个人。也就是约翰·鲍尔，我们稍后会讲到他。哦，约翰·鲍尔。是的。这就是约翰·鲍尔一直在活动的地方，我们可能正在看到
of his teachings here. But I think it's not just the ideological seasoning. There's also been very, very clear planning because the rebels are very targeted in what they attack. They're not just pillaging and looting here and there. They're targeting specific properties, the properties of people whom the mass of people in Essex have particular reason to dislike. So they target a monastery in Essex that is owned by the Knights Hospitallers. And of course, the Knights Hospitallers, their prior is Sir Robert Hales, who is the treasurer. They torch the house of Sir John Gillsborough, the Speaker, who had been at Brentwood. So that's very targeted, but that's not to deny that there isn't also violence.
他教导的影响。但我认为这不仅仅是意识形态的渲染。还有非常、非常明确的计划，因为叛军的攻击目标非常明确。他们不仅仅是在这里或那里掠夺。他们针对的是特定的财产，是埃塞克斯大众有特别理由厌恶的人的财产。所以他们袭击了埃塞克斯一座由医院骑士团拥有的修道院。当然，医院骑士团的院长是罗伯特·黑尔斯爵士，他也是财政大臣。他们烧毁了曾在布伦特伍德的议长约翰·吉尔斯伯勒爵士的房子。所以这是非常有针对性的，但这并不否认暴力事件的存在。
So they capture the official who's responsible for all the poll tax assessments in Essex. They chop off his head and they stick his head on a lance and they kind of braid it around going hurrah, hurrah. Okay, well, that's a slightly different dimension then to the, oh, these are aspirational people who just want a better field. Well, I think you can be both. I think you can be an aspirational person and prone to violence. So to sound like Simon Sharma, violence is inherent in the revolution from the very beginning. I think that there is targeted violence against people who are particularly identified with oppression from the beginning. Yeah. And if they can't get these individuals in person, then they will target their property. So that's why, say, three of Gillsborough's houses across Essex are destroyed. It's very, very deliberate.
他们抓住了负责埃塞克斯所有人头税评估的官员。他们砍下了他的头，把它插在长矛上，然后举着它到处游行，高喊“万岁，万岁”。好吧，那这和“这些人只是想要更好田地的有抱负的人”的说法相比，就有了不同的维度。嗯，我认为你可以两者兼备。我认为你可以是一个有抱负的人，同时也容易诉诸暴力。用西蒙·沙玛的话来说，暴力从一开始就存在于革命之中。我认为从一开始就有针对那些被特别视为压迫者的人的暴力行为。是的。如果他们不能亲自抓住这些人，那么他们就会针对他们的财产。这就是为什么吉尔斯伯勒在埃塞克斯的三处房产被摧毁的原因。这是非常、非常蓄意的。
But I think the really unsurprising but momentous development is that what gets particularly targeted are these repositories of documents. And this happens across Essex. Essentially, what people are trying to do is to destroy the apparatus of royal government within the county and the ability of local landlords, including the abbeys, to impose the taxes and the dues and obligations that these papers specify. Because if the records of the dues and obligations are destroyed, there will be no longer any basis for the landowners to demand that. Well, that'd be oral tradition. There would be, but you can kind of ignore that.
但我认为真正令人不意外但意义重大的发展是，被特别针对的是这些文件库。这种情况在埃塞克斯各地都有发生。本质上，人们试图做的是摧毁郡内的皇家政府机构，以及包括修道院在内的当地地主强加这些文件所规定的税收、会费和义务的能力。因为如果这些会费和义务的记录被销毁，地主们就再也没有依据来索要这些东西了。嗯，那还会有口头传统。确实会有，但你可以忽略它。
You can. Well, you can contest it. And that would give the aspirational people a chance then to break away from the network of obligations and to forge new careers and lives themselves. Yeah. Well, so that will require the king to agree to it. And so this is a kind of looming further dimension is, do we stay in the county or do we perhaps march on London and try and get the king to change things? Now, the people of Essex can't do that themselves, but they can do it if they have allies in other counties. It so happens that at the same time, things are also kicking off in Kent. In Kent, likewise, there have been provocations. John Legge, the guy who was the upskirter, he's been very active in Kent. Then there's a
你可以。嗯，你可以质疑它。这将给那些有抱负的人一个机会，让他们摆脱义务网络，开创自己的新事业和新生活。是的。嗯，那将需要国王的同意。所以这是一个隐约可见的进一步维度：我们是留在郡里，还是进军伦敦，试图让国王改变现状？现在，埃塞克斯的人民自己做不到这一点，但如果他们在其他郡有盟友，他们就能做到。恰好在同一时间，肯特郡也开始行动了。在肯特郡，同样也存在挑衅行为。那个“掀裙子”的家伙约翰·莱格在肯特郡非常活跃。然后发生了一件
particular outrage because there's a villain from Essex called Robert Belling, who is seized and imprisoned in Rochester Castle. A gang of rebels come together, they march on the castle. The castle is in a very ruinous state because there's been a flood and the gateway has been demolished in the flow of water. The rebels are able to get in. They capture the children of the constable, a guy called Sir John Newington. So Newington surrenders. From this point on, Newington is basically kept to serve as the spokesman of the rebels to the king because he is a man of high standing. They want him to be the go-between between them and the king. So they're already thinking, well, we should take this further. We should march on London. And before the men of Kent march on London, they do what's been going on in Essex as well. So they're sending horsemen out across the country to raise villages everywhere.
特别令人愤慨的事情，因为一个叫罗伯特·贝林的埃塞克斯恶棍在罗切斯特城堡被抓获并监禁。一群叛军聚集在一起，向城堡进军。城堡处于非常破败的状态，因为发生过洪水，大门在水流中被冲毁了。叛军得以进入。他们抓住了治安官约翰·纽因顿爵士的孩子。所以纽因顿投降了。从这一点开始，纽因顿基本上被留下来作为叛军对国王的发言人，因为他是一位地位很高的人。他们希望他成为他们和国王之间的中间人。所以他们已经在想，嗯，我们应该把这件事进一步扩大。我们应该进军伦敦。在肯特人进军伦敦之前，他们做了埃塞克斯也在做的事情。所以他们派出骑兵到全国各地，在各个村庄发动起义。
They are staging bonfires of legal documents. They're hunting down MPs and JPs. And they even managed to capture Canterbury. And of course, Sudbury, the Archbishop of Canterbury, a particular object of hate as the Lord Chancellor, but he's not there, but the rebels proclaim that he is deposed as Archbishop of Canterbury. They do, however, manage to capture the Sheriff of Kent, and they frog march him to his house on the outskirts of Canterbury, where all the records for the county are kept, and they frog march him to his house on the outskirts of Canterbury, where all the records for the county are kept.
他们正在举行焚烧法律文件的篝火晚会。他们正在追捕议员和治安法官。他们甚至成功占领了坎特伯雷。当然，坎特伯雷大主教萨德伯里作为大法官是一个特别的仇恨对象，但他不在那里，但叛军宣布他被罢免了坎特伯雷大主教的职务。然而，他们确实成功抓住了肯特郡的治安官，并强迫他步行到坎特伯雷郊外的家中，那里保存着该郡所有的记录，他们强迫他步行到坎特伯雷郊外的家中，那里保存着该郡所有的记录。
He is obliged to hand over all the rolls, and they light a great fire in the middle of Canterbury and publicly burn them. So again, it's this systematic attempt to destroy the paper records that enable royal government to be upheld. Undoubtedly, once this has been completed, there are many rebels in both Essex and Kent who feel that they've done what they set out to do. But there are others, as I said, who think we can't end here. The only way that we can absolutely secure the abolition of all these obligations and
他被迫交出所有的卷宗，他们在坎特伯雷中心点燃了一场大火，公开烧毁了它们。所以这又是一次系统性的尝试，旨在摧毁使皇家政府得以维持的纸质记录。毫无疑问，一旦这一切完成，埃塞克斯和肯特郡的许多叛军都觉得他们已经完成了他们想要做的事情。但正如我所说，还有其他人认为我们不能在这里结束。我们能够绝对确保废除所有这些义务的唯一途径，以及
dues that are imposed on us as rustiki is to get the king to agree to it yeah and these ambitions coalesce around two figures who are really you know these are the men who are most associated in the popular mind i guess with what we call the peasants revolt and the first of these is what tyler soatt Tyler, for people not familiar with this story, Watt Tyler is without doubt seen in the popular imagination as the figurehead of the Peasants' Revolt, but also as a foundational figure in what people imagine to be the radical left-wing English tradition. He's exactly the kind of person, if you're at some sort of big May Day trade union meeting in 2023 or 2024, somebody might well say, ever since the days of what, Tyler? And everyone would cheer and know who he was. And I think that he deserves this reputation. He is clearly a man of incredible ability. The frustration is we don't know much about him. Well, in fact, we know almost nothing about him before 1381. So maybe he's a Tyler. Who knows?
作为“乡下人”被强加给我们的会费，就是让国王同意。是的，这些野心围绕着两个人物凝聚在一起，他们真的是，我想在公众心目中与我们所说的“农民起义”联系最紧密的人，第一个就是瓦特·泰勒。对于不熟悉这个故事的人来说，瓦特·泰勒无疑被视为农民起义的领袖，也被视为人们想象中英国激进左翼传统的奠基人物。他正是那种人，如果你在2023年或2024年的某个大型五一工会会议上，有人很可能会说：“自从瓦特·泰勒时代以来？”每个人都会欢呼，知道他是谁。我认为他配得上这个名声。他显然是一个能力非凡的人。令人沮丧的是，我们对他知之甚少。事实上，在1381年之前，我们对他几乎一无所知。所以也许他是个瓦特（瓦匠）。谁知道呢？
He seems to have been so competent as a leader that some people have suggested that maybe he'd fought in the Hundred Years' War, that he had military experience. We don't even really know where he comes from. So one chronicler describes him as coming from Maidstone in Kent, but we have a legal record which describes him as being from Essex. I mean, maybe he's both, maybe he's a man of Essex who's moved to Kent. And legally you're not allowed to do that. So if that is the case, then that might kind of explain why he's so ready to join the rebellion. But the truth is that he emerges very, very rapidly, as in the word of one document, the captain and leader of the men in Kent. And it is under Tyler's leadership that the men of Kent decide that they are going to march on London. And even as they are doing that,
他似乎作为领导者非常称职，以至于有些人认为他可能参加过百年战争，有军事经验。我们甚至不知道他来自哪里。一位编年史家描述他来自肯特郡的梅德斯通，但我们有一份法律记录描述他来自埃塞克斯。我的意思是，也许他两者都是，也许他是一个搬到肯特郡的埃塞克斯人。而在法律上是不允许这样做的。所以如果是这样的话，那可能解释了他为什么如此急于参加叛乱。但事实是，他非常迅速地崛起，用一份文件的话说，是“肯特郡人的队长和领袖”。正是在泰勒的领导下，肯特人决定进军伦敦。即使在他们这样做的时候，
people in Essex and Suffolk are doing the same. And the likelihood is that it is Tyler who is coordinating this. I mean, if he has come from Essex, then perhaps he has links there. So the Kentishmen under Tyler, they've taken Canterbury, they've had their great bonfire, they've deposed the Archbishop. And on the 10th of June, they leave Canterbury and they take the Pilgrim Road that heads towards London. Now, what are their goals? People might suspect that their goal is to abolish the poll tax because, Dominic, this was the spark that lit the kindling. But as far as we know, they don't mention the poll tax. This seems to have gone as a concern. They now have much higher goals because their agenda is unbelievably radical. They want the complete abolition of serfdom. They want legal recognition
埃塞克斯和萨福克的人民也在做同样的事情。很有可能正是泰勒在协调这一切。我的意思是，如果他来自埃塞克斯，那么也许他在那里有联系。所以泰勒领导下的肯特人占领了坎特伯雷，举行了盛大的篝火晚会，罢免了大主教。6月10日，他们离开坎特伯雷，走上了通往伦敦的朝圣之路。那么，他们的目标是什么？人们可能会怀疑他们的目标是废除人头税，因为多米尼克，这就是点燃干柴的火花。但据我们所知，他们没有提到人头税。这似乎已经不再是一个关注点。他们现在有了更高的目标，因为他们的议程极其激进。他们想要彻底废除农奴制。他们想要法律承认
of a worker's right to work for whom he wants, where he wants, on such wages as he can command. And they want all the wealth of the church, all the abbeys, all the monasteries to be seized. Because they see the churches and the abbeys and the monasteries as highly oppressive. So this is an incredible bundle of aims. Obviously, in the 21st century, lots of keen political activists have seen this as proto-socialist. But could you also see this as proto-Protestant, Tom, with the attack on the established church? Yes, I absolutely think you could. And as we said before, these are the regions that will be the heartlands of the Protestant Reformation in due course. And this is where I think you see the influence of this very, very mysterious, enigmatic, but clearly highly
工人有权为他想为的人工作，在任何他想工作的地方，以他能要求的工资工作。他们想要没收教会所有的财富，所有的修道院。因为他们认为教堂、修道院和寺院是高度压迫性的。所以这是一系列令人难以置信的目标。显然，在21世纪，许多热心的政治活动家将其视为原始社会主义。但汤姆，你是否也可以将其视为原始新教，因为他们攻击了既定教会？是的，我绝对认为你可以。正如我们之前所说，这些地区在未来将成为新教改革的核心地带。我认为在这里你可以看到这位非常、非常神秘、难以捉摸，但显然极具
influential figure, John Ball, with his Adam Delving and Eve Spinning, who then was a gentleman, rhyming. So John Ball seems, I mean, again, the records of his life are scanty, but to the degree that we can piece them together, he seems to be an Essex boy, an Essex lad, probably from Colchester. He seems to have been trained, interestingly, as a priest in York, and then he's moved back by Norwich back to Colchester. And he is constantly having run-ins with Simon Sudbury, who's become the Archbishop of Canterbury by this point, but who previously had been the Bishop of London, and as Bishop of London, had responsibility for quite a lot of Essex. Sudbury had secured a condemnation of John Ball as a vagabond and a man
影响的人物约翰·鲍尔的影响，他那句“当亚当耕种，夏娃纺纱，谁是绅士”的押韵。所以约翰·鲍尔似乎，嗯，同样，他生平的记录很少，但就我们能拼凑出来的程度来看，他似乎是个埃塞克斯男孩，埃塞克斯小伙，可能来自科尔切斯特。有趣的是，他似乎在约克受过牧师培训，然后从诺里奇搬回了科尔切斯特。他不断与西蒙·萨德伯里发生冲突，萨德伯里此时已成为坎特伯雷大主教，但之前曾是伦敦主教，作为伦敦主教，他负责埃塞克斯的大部分地区。萨德伯里曾确保约翰·鲍尔被谴责为流浪汉和一个人，
who preaches doctrines contrary to the faith of the church, to the peril of his own soul and those of others. And in 1375, this excommunication of John Ball had been confirmed by Sudbury. And then just as the revolt is starting to kick off, just before it kind of really bursts into flames, Sudbury issues an order that Ball should be arrested, almost as though he is alert to the kind of ideological underpinnings of what's going on. Sudbury accuses Ball of being a false prophet, of being a man whose sermons reek of heretical depravity, a man who is not preaching in church, he's preaching in public spaces, public places, and that John Ball is attacking not only the wealthy, the landowners, but he's attacking the entire hierarchy of the church right the way up to the Pope himself.
他宣扬违背教会信仰的教义，危及他自己的灵魂和他人的灵魂。1375年，约翰·鲍尔的绝罚令得到了萨德伯里的确认。就在叛乱开始爆发时，就在它真正爆发成火焰之前，萨德伯里下令逮捕鲍尔，几乎就像他意识到正在发生的事情的意识形态基础一样。萨德伯里指责鲍尔是一个假先知，是一个布道散发着异端堕落气息的人，一个不在教堂布道，而在公共空间、公共场所布道的人，而且约翰·鲍尔不仅在攻击富人、地主，他还在攻击整个教会等级制度，一直到教皇本人。
And in particular, Sudbury complains John Ball is attacking Sudbury himself. So it's personal. Yeah. John Ball, Sudbury says, is spreading scandals about our person. So all of this suggests that Ball is pretty notorious by this time among the clerical hierarchy, and probably that he has been active in all the areas where the revolt bursts into flames. That he really is the person who is encouraging people to think in this almost apocalyptic tone.
特别是，萨德伯里抱怨约翰·鲍尔在攻击萨德伯里本人。所以这是个人的。是的。萨德伯里说，约翰·鲍尔正在散布关于我们个人的丑闻。所以所有这些都表明，鲍尔在当时的神职人员阶层中相当臭名昭著，而且他很可能在叛乱爆发的所有地区都很活跃。他确实是在鼓励人们以这种近乎末日的基调思考的人。
Yeah, like a kind of evangelical preacher roaming the land, stirring the people up, basically. Yeah, and I think that one of the things that kind of points to this is that the 2nd of June, which is the day of the Bocking meeting, the kind of the mass assembly in Essex, is also Whitsun, Pentecost, which is the day on which the Holy Spirit descends on the apostles and animates the functioning of the entire church. And the Acts of the Apostles records what that meant in practice. So the whole group of those who believed, I'm quoting from Acts of the Apostles records what that meant in practice. So the whole group of those who believed, I'm quoting from Acts of the Apostles, were of one heart and soul, and no one claimed private ownership of any possessions, but everything they owned was held in
是的，就像一个在土地上游荡的福音派传教士，基本上是在煽动人民。是的，我认为指向这一点的事情之一是6月2日，也就是博金会议的日子，埃塞克斯的大规模集会，也是圣灵降临节，这是圣灵降临在使徒身上并激活整个教会运作的日子。《使徒行传》记录了这意味着什么。所以所有相信的人群，我引用《使徒行传》记录了这意味着什么。所以所有相信的人群，我引用《使徒行传》，都是一心一意的，没有人声称私有财产，但他们拥有的一切都是
common. So that is a kind of scriptural sanction for what you might almost call communism, a kind of radical idea that everything should be held in possession. Maybe Ball is preaching on this topic on that very day. I'd be very surprised if he wasn't. However, the record of Ball preaching that you began this episode with, that's on the 12th of June. As Walsingham noted, it's preached at Blackheath, which is a great assembly point to the southeast of London. London is visible from it, and this is where all the men of Kent gather. And Walsingham's account of Ball's sermon that he gives there, as you said, Walsingham is not in favour of it. He thinks it's terrible. Kill all
共有的。所以这是一种对你几乎可以称之为共产主义的东西的圣经制裁，一种认为一切都应该共有的激进思想。也许鲍尔在那一天就在讲这个话题。如果他没有讲，我会非常惊讶。然而，你在这集开头提到的鲍尔布道的记录，那是在6月12日。正如沃尔辛厄姆指出的那样，它是在布莱克希思布道的，那是伦敦东南部的一个大集会点。从那里可以看到伦敦，这就是所有肯特人聚集的地方。沃尔辛厄姆对鲍尔在那里发表的布道的描述，正如你所说，沃尔辛厄姆并不赞成。他认为这太可怕了。杀死所有
the lords, king all the lawyers, all this kind of stuff, which is what makes it so ironic that it's become so iconic. Walsingham, in a way, by trying to damn John Ball, has given him a kind of immortality. Except Dominic, there is a problem. Ball never gave that sermon. He was not at Blackheath on the 12th of June. Because he'd been in prison in Essex. Is that right? He'd been in prison and he's only released on the 11th of June. Couldn't have got there in time. There's no way he could have got there in time. No, it's such a shame. And there's no contemporary record that places him in London at all
领主，杀死所有律师，所有这些东西，这正是它变得如此具有标志性的讽刺之处。沃尔辛厄姆在某种程度上，通过试图谴责约翰·鲍尔，给了他一种不朽。多米尼克，除了有一个问题。鲍尔从未发表过那次布道。6月12日他不在布莱克希思。因为他一直被关在埃塞克斯的监狱里。是这样吗？他一直被关在监狱里，直到6月11日才被释放。不可能及时赶到那里。他根本不可能及时赶到那里。不，真是太遗憾了。而且没有同时代的记录将他置于伦敦
in this period. But you say that's a shame, but isn't that incredibly revealing that the people who are telling the story of the Peasants' Revolt are hyping up John Ball's role, presumably because they know that their readers or their listeners or whatever, the people who consume this, will be horrified by Ball's egalitarianism and will regard him as a madman. Yeah. And the Peasants' Revolt will therefore be tainted by association. Yes.
在这一时期。但你说那很遗憾，但这难道不令人难以置信地揭示了那些讲述农民起义故事的人在炒作约翰·鲍尔的角色吗？大概是因为他们知道他们的读者或听众，或者任何消费这些内容的人，会被鲍尔的平等主义所震惊，并会把他视为疯子。是的。因此，农民起义会因这种联系而受到玷污。是的。
It's kind of Daily Mail editorial wanting to make Middle England's blood run cold by suggesting all the horrors that Jeremy Corbyn might want to unleash as Prime Minister. It's that kind of thing. I'm very familiar with such pieces, Tom. Are you? I had no idea. So in this sense, I think the emphasis on John Ball in Walsingham's account, this is Sandbrook as Daily Mail columnist. But as I say, the paradox is that it serves to immortalise John Ball. He's enshrined as this great spokesman, which I think he probably was. It's just that the sermon wasn't on Blackheath. They were probably being given it
这有点像《每日邮报》的社论，想要通过暗示杰里米·科尔宾作为首相可能释放的所有恐怖来让英格兰中产阶级感到胆寒。就是那种东西。汤姆，我对这样的文章非常熟悉。是吗？我一点都不知道。所以在这个意义上，我认为沃尔辛厄姆的叙述中对约翰·鲍尔的强调，这就是桑德布鲁克作为《每日邮报》专栏作家。但正如我所说，悖论在于它起到了让约翰·鲍尔不朽的作用。他被奉为这位伟大的发言人，我认为他可能确实是。只是布道不是在布莱克希思。他们可能是在
in Essex. And I think indisputably, the rebels are motivated by radical views in which politics and religion are kind of indistinguishable in the way that they so often are in the Middle Ages. And he didn't have to be at Blackheath for his teachings to have had a profound impact. So in strictly kind of historical detail, Ball wasn't at Blackheath, but his spirit was there. He was very much there in spirit. Am I right in thinking that like so many later revolutions, the story of this is really that what has happened is the intersection of material grievances, which are based actually not on poverty and inequality, but on frustrated completely understand in the aftermath of the Black Death. And those two things have now become completely fused. So some of those people who have been marching on London might have started their grievances
埃塞克斯被给予的。我认为毫无疑问，叛军的动机是激进的观点，其中政治和宗教在某种程度上是不可区分的，就像它们在中世纪经常出现的那样。他不必在布莱克希思，他的教导就能产生深远的影响。所以在严格的历史细节上，鲍尔不在布莱克希思，但他的精神在那里。他在精神上非常在那里。我是否认为像许多后来的革命一样，这个故事实际上是物质不满的交集，这些不满实际上不是基于贫困和不平等，而是基于在黑死病之后完全可以理解的受挫。而这两件事现在已经完全融合了。所以那些进军伦敦的人中，有些人可能已经开始了他们的不满
actually about the Baltics and about some incredibly mundane dispute about a field. And now they are full of the zeal, the Holy Spirit, as you might say, because of John Ball's teachings. Yeah. And what Ball is doing and why this kind of looks forward to the Reformation is that there is a kind of strain of radical egalitarianism within Christianity. You know, the apostles do hold all their possessions in common. And obviously, the spectacle of John of Gaunt in the Savoy Palace or the Archbishop of Canterbury or all
实际上是关于人头税和关于田地的一些极其平凡的纠纷。现在他们充满了热情，正如你可能说的圣灵，因为约翰·鲍尔的教导。是的。鲍尔正在做的事情，以及为什么这看起来有点像宗教改革，是因为基督教内部有一种激进的平等主义。你知道，使徒们确实拥有他们所有的共同财产。显然，萨伏伊宫的冈特的约翰，或者坎特伯雷大主教，或者所有
the hierarchies or the abbeys and monasteries that are screwing money out of peasants. I mean, this obviously can be cast as opposed to God's wishes. So that also provides a sanction for what is happening. And when you combine that with the obvious ability of what Tyler to organize and coordinate the attack, because even as the men of Kent are massing on Blackheath, people from Essex and Suffolk are starting to gather on Mile End, which is directly outside the eastern walls of the City of London. You have this extraordinary situation where London effectively is going to come under siege. All the elites of England are inside the city. You have the King, the 14-year-old Richard II. You have the Archbishop of Canterbury.
那些从农民身上榨钱的等级制度或修道院和寺院的景象。我的意思是，这显然可以被视为违背上帝的意愿。所以这也为正在发生的事情提供了制裁。当你把这一点与瓦特·泰勒组织和协调攻击的明显能力结合起来时，因为即使肯特人在布莱克希思集结，埃塞克斯和萨福克的人民也开始在迈尔恩德聚集，那就在伦敦城东墙外。你面临着这种情况，伦敦实际上将受到围困。英国所有的精英都在城内。你有国王，14岁的理查二世。你有坎特伯雷大主教。
You have the treasurer. What are they to do? Because they are now staring down the barrel of something that no royal government has ever had to face before in England, which is a genuine popular revolt. What a cliffhanger, Tom. They are staring down the barrel. Staring down the barrel, don't they? It could not be more exciting. Now, if you are a member of the Rest is History Club,
你有财政大臣。他们该怎么办？因为他们现在正盯着英国皇家政府以前从未面对过的东西，那就是一场真正的民众起义。汤姆，真是个悬念。他们正盯着枪口。盯着枪口，不是吗？这再令人兴奋不过了。现在，如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，
and that works on very egalitarian principles, with the exception of me and Tom, who are right at the top, untouchable. And it has a kind of poll tax, but we won't get into all that. If you're a member of the Rest Is History Club, you can find out what happens after this thrilling cliffhanger. You can find that out right now. You can just listen right away. If you have not paid that particular poll tax, then your prospects are grim in the next couple of days because you'll have nothing to listen to.
这遵循非常平等的原则，除了我和汤姆，我们处于最顶端，不可触碰。它有一种人头税，但我们不会深入讨论所有这些。如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你可以找出这个惊心动魄的悬念之后发生了什么。你现在就可以找出答案。你可以马上听。如果你没有支付那个人头税，那么你在接下来的几天里前景黯淡，因为你将没有什么可听的。
And you'll have to wait till Thursday when things will look up for you and you'll find out what happened. So it's very exciting. You know, the storm clouds are gathering once more. The fires are lit. You know, all cliches are operational. And we'll see you next time for the conclusion of the Peasants' Revolt. Bye-bye.
你将不得不等到周四，那时情况会好转，你会发现发生了什么。所以这非常令人兴奋。你知道，乌云再次聚集。火被点燃了。你知道，所有的陈词滥调都在运作。我们下次再见，完成农民起义的结论。再见。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持“娱乐的其余部分”。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。